you've probably never heard of Sierra
Nevada despite the fact that they
launched something into orbit about
every two to three weeks Sierra Nevada
has been around for over 50 years and
employs more than 3000 people in 16
states one of the things people see when
they come here it's they see wonderful
technology they see a spaceship that's
already flying in a short period of time
NASA is hosting a competition for
private enterprise to build a spacecraft
to shuttle humans back and forth to
low-earth orbit and that contract will
be worth billions Sierra Nevadas dream
chaser design is the only one in the
competition that is not a capsule it's a
lifting body all right I'm ready to take
a look at this freeing phaser let's go
fly one model is the only one that
actually looks like the shuttle what's
interesting about this is actually the
volume inside is as much usable volume
as the Space Shuttle had we could put
seven people it would be a comfortable
fit and they could stay in space for
several days if they need to with enough
supplies really like a space SUV yes so
far there hasn't been a capsule that
speaking humans have gone up to space so
one might have to build 20 or 30 or 40
capsules to do the same thing that we
can do
one space vehicle when you look at the
economics of that that's a really
important thing all right let's jump in
this simulator okay let's get the fast I
see the runway there yeah doesn't fly
like an airplane but it lands like an
airplane the fact that the Dream Chaser
requires a landing strip that sets it
apart from the competition for us we can
land pretty much on any runway 8,000
feet or longer in the world because we
don't enter like a capsule we pull a lot
less G's on entry we come in at a very
low one-and-a-half G so you can come in
land on runway with a sensitive payload
the scientists can get to that payload
within 30 minutes because it's right
there on the runway you guys are up
against Boeing and SpaceX what makes you
think that you can take them on how many
people knew Google before they started
we think dreamchaser is the best
transportation system for what we do in
space it's almost like we're building
the iPad and other people are building
the apps in the future from that iPad